[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen zu sallyys
Welt heute habe ich eine Ostertorte für
euch und zwar habe ich eine 2 in1 Torte
gemacht nämlich eine Ostertorte mit
einem dripcake kombiniert dripcake das
ist eine Torte
die ist gerade momentan sehr im Trend
die gibt's auch wirklich in allen
verschiedenen allen möglichen
Variationen die man sich ausdenken kann
und zwar eine Torte die schön glatt
gestrichen wird und dann mit Kuvertüre
z.B oder mit einer Glasur überzogen wird
und die am Rand dann eben so schön
runterläuft genau die Samira ist auch
frisch mit dabei und Samira hat ein
zuckersüßes Osterhäschen gemacht mit
einer
lato so süß ich ma dort noch vorne was
hin okay du bist sch nicht fertig alles
klar ich habe die Torte ziemlich hoch
gestaltet weil ich einfach schön finde
wenn gerade diese dripcakes einfach
schön hoch sind da hat mal am Rand viel
Platz um etwas runterlaufen zu lassen
hier oben sitzen zwei zuckersüße kleine
Häschen und die Häschen wollten
eigentlich gerade die Ostereier bemalen
und haben dann deswegen die Farbe in die
Farbtöpfe gemacht und die Farbe ist halt
an der Torte entlang runtergelaufen voll
süß gell ja schön gewesen noch Pinsel da
was wenn sie noch Pinsel in der Hand h
Pinsel da doch einer in der Schürze okay
gesehen doch weil doch jetzt fertig ach
Gott ja echt süß ich zeige euch jetzt
mal wie ich die Torte gebacken habe im
Innern steckt eine pistazientorte mit
einer waldfruchteinlage einer Himbeer
bututtercreme und hier außen habe ich
eine vanillebuttercreme echt lecker ich
zeige euch jetzt erst einmal die Zutaten
für den Teig und dann starten wir auch
gleich genau kennst du das eigentlich
wenn man so Bilder malt und Anh der
Bilder sagen
Psychologe was du für irgendwelche
Störungen hast oder oder oder irgendwas
kennst du das ja hab bei kleines Kind
bei dir auch gemacht so so mal so ein
Bild mach nur bei auffällige bei
auffälligen Kindern okay schau dir mal
bitte den Hasen den süßen Hasen von der
Samira an das heißt das ist Mamas Kind
ich glaube wenn Psychologe diesen Hasen
sieht dann lande ich im Knast
wahrscheinlich der
ist so osterh se der ist richtig schön
der hat ein richtig hartes Wochenende
hinter sich gehab Gott sei Dank kanast
du Mama
gehell h auf der Papa für für den
pistazienteig brauche ich drei Eier 150
g Zucker eine Prise Salz etwas
Vanilleextrakt jeweils 150 ml
Sonnenblumenöl und Buttermilch hier habe
ich eineinhalb Teelöffel Backpulver 200
g Mehl und 100 g Pistazien die werde ich
jetzt gleich fein
[Musik]
hacken
den Teig fülle ich jetzt in meine zwei
vorbereiteten backringe und zwar haben
die jeweils 20 cm im Durchmesser und ich
backe das gerne in zwei Ringen weil
einfach dann der Teig besser aufgeht und
ich einfach zwei gleichmäßige Böden
habe den Teig streiche ich immer gerne
am ein bisschen hoch dann geht er
gleichmäßiger
auf und die zwei werden jetzt so
gebacken und dann werde ich den gleichen
Teig noch einmal zubereiten noch mal
zwei Tortenböden backen damit ich
einfach eine extra hohe Torte
hinbekomme die Tortenböden werden jetzt
im vorgeheizenen Backofen bei 170°
oberunterhitze für etwa 30 bis 35
Minuten
[Musik]
gebacken jetzt kommen wir zum fruchtigen
teil und zwar werde ich jetzt eine
fruchteinlage machen fruchteinlagen sind
super lecker und vor allem sehr
praktisch denn dafür werden die Früchte
oder das Obst eben fein püriert
eingekocht und dadurch ist die Torte
auch länger haltbar und es zermatscht
eben nicht so wie wenn ich jetzt frische
Früchte in die Torte mit reingeben würde
ich habe jetzt hier bereits eine
fruchteinlage vorbereitet dafür habe ich
jetzt gemischte Früchte genommen und sie
auf dem Herd einkochen lassen und dann
auch agatin mit Wasser aufgekocht und
das ganze jetzt verrührt dafür findet
ihr das Rezept auch auf meinem Blog als
Grundrezept hier habe ich jetzt die
komplette Masse und dadurch dass ich
jetzt vier gebackene Böden habe und sie
später durchschneiden werde brauche ich
sechs verschiedene Füllungen und ich
mache das normalerweise immer so dass
ich einen Backring nehme also einen
Tortenring den stelle ich auf eine mit
Frischhaltefolie belegte Tortenplatte
also hier auf einen tortenretter und
fülle das hier ein und so kann ich es
dann eben schön einfrieren ich habe
jetzt aber auch selbst nur einen
Tortenring mit 14 cm Durchmesser das wä
jetzt nämlich meine gewünschte Größe
fruchteinlagen müssen nämlich immer ein
bisschen kleiner sein als die Torte
damit man sie von aus einfach nicht
sieht deswegen mache ich das jetzt
einmal so einmal fülle ich das jetzt
hier ein und dann nehme ich wie
wahrscheinlich jeder andere auch einfach
verschiedene Teller und zwar sind die
jetzt gleich groß und haben hier so eine
kleine
Vertiefung und es passt jetzt von der
Größe her ganz gut ich werde es hier
einfüllen und später einfach auf die
richtige Größe
ausstechen so jetzt verteile ich das
einfach gleichmäßig hier drauf und dafür
wiege ich die Masse immer ab und füll
dann die gleiche Menge einfach schön
ein
[Musik]
so jetzt habe ich die erste
fruchteinlage fertig die kommt jetzt so
in den Gefrierschrank und muss dann für
etwa eine halbe Stunde eingefrauen
werden und die restlichen mache ich wie
gesagt in die tell
[Musik]
rein während die fruchteinlagen jetzt
noch fest werden kann ich schon mal die
Creme vorbereiten und ich mache jetzt
eine französische Buttercreme das ist
wirklich eine meiner
lieblingsbuttercremes denn sie schmeckt
auch nicht so nach Butter sondern viel
mehr ja so ganz locker und leicht und
die Buttercreme kann man entweder als
vanillebuttercreme machen als
schokobuttercreme oder so wie ich heute
als fruchtbuttercreme dafür habe ich
hier jetzt schon mal ein paar himbeen
aus dem tiefkülfach einfach auftauen
lassen und hier eingekocht die werde ich
jetzt gleich weiter verarbeiten werde
aber hier einfach schon mal die
fruchtbuttercreme zubereiten die
Eiermasse schlagen und dafür gibt's auch
das Rezept bereits als Basic auf meinem
Blog
ich mache das ganze jetzt hier heute in
meiner Küchenmaschine mit hitzefunktion
so mache ich es am liebsten weil es eben
am einfachsten geht ich kann nämlich
hier die Maschine auf 85° einstellen und
das ganze dann eben rühren lassen falls
ihr keine kenwur habt könnt ihr das
ganze natürlich auch über dem heißen
Wasserbad machen auf dem Herd da müsst
Ihr einfach schön dabei sein und das
Wasser kochen lassen und währenddessen
eben fleißig
[Musik]
rühren
so jetzt ist die Eiermasse fertig ich
habe nach 10 Minuten aufschlagen mit
Hitze die Temperatur weg men das ist
auch der Punkt wo man dann eben die
Eiermasse vom Wasserbad herunternimmt
und dann muss man sie noch kalt rühren
und dann hat man eine richtig schöne
dickflüssige Creme die stelle ich jetzt
kurz zur Seite und werde in der
Zwischenzeit jetzt schon mal die Butter
maximal schaumig schlagen das heißt die
Butter wird 4 bis 5 Minuten lang richtig
schön cremig und locker
gerührt so sieht die Butter jetzt aus
also richtig schön weiß jetzt werde ich
die Eiermasse unter die Butter
heben
[Musik]
und an dieser Stelle gebe ich jetzt die
pürierten Früchte mit rein die habe ich
ja lange genug einkochen lassen so dass
eben fast keine Flüssigkeit mehr drin
steckt denenn ich möchte jetzt einfach
nicht viel Feuchtigkeit und viel Wasser
einfach in die buttercem bringen ich
soll schön cremig und geschmeidig sein
jetzt gibt ihr da einfach nach Geschmack
mit dazu könnt die Creme immer mal
wieder abschmecken und dann stelle ich
sie ganz kurz in den Kühlschrank bis ich
dann mit den Rest Sachen hier
vorbereitet bin und die Torte dann
zusammenetzen
[Musik]
kann so bei dieser fruchteinlage hier
habe ich jetzt die perfekte Größe jetzt
nehme ich den Ring und stelle jetzt auch
die anderen aus ihr könnt es aber auch
ganz anders machen ihr könnt auch z.B
eine große Platte Gießen auf dem
Backblech z.B und danach dann einfach
mit dem hier ausstechen also macht
einfach so wie es am einfachsten für
euch ist ich werde jetzt aus stechen und
dann kann ich die Torte gleich
befüllen die Tortenböden schneide ich
jetzt alle mit einer tortensäge durch
und da ist es immer am besten wenn ihr
die tortenböten bereits am Vortag
zubereitet dann kümeln sie nämlich nicht
so dann sind sie ein bisschen fester und
es geht einfacher jetzt geht's ans
stapeln der Torte dafür nehme ich jetzt
eine tortendrehplatte da geht's nämlich
am besten weil man die Torte drehen kann
und währenddessen eben auch schön
streichen kann jetzt nehme ich erstmal
eine Pappunterlage und später setze ich
die Torte dann eben auch eine schöne
chere
drauf nehme jetzt einfach den ersten
[Musik]
Tortenboden hier streiche ich jetzt ein
bisschen Buttercreme drauf dann lege ich
die fruchteinlage drauf und bedeck sie
wieder mit Buttercreme und so wird jetzt
die ganze Torte schön
hochgestapelt jetzt kommt bei mir die
letzte Etage drauf ich habe dann einen
Tortenboden übrig aber das ist gar nicht
schlimm dann kann man auch einiss
[Musik]
so Deckel oben drauf und jetzt habe ich
die gewünschte Höhe erreicht ihr müsst
einfach schauen dass die Torte nicht zu
hoch wird dann wird s auch ebenabil und
es Set dann auch irgendwann nicht mehr
schön aus ich finde Höhe so jetzt
ziemlich gut denn bei dripcakes ist ganz
wichtig dass S schön hoch werden damit
man am Rand schön was runter fließen
lassen kann und die Torte muss jetzt
aber erst einmal in den Kühlschrank oder
ins gefrierfache ich werde sie jetzt
etwa für eine halbe Stunde ins
Gefrierfach stellen so wird die
Buttercreme jetzt schön fest und ich
kann dann die Torte mit der Buttercreme
schön glatt
[Musik]
streichen die Torte ist jetzt gut
durchgekühlt und die restliche Creme
habe ich einfach noch an den Rand
gestrichen um hier hier diese Lücken zu
schließen jetzt habe ich hier noch mal
eine Portion Buttercreme und zwar eine
Vanille Buttercreme auch die
französische ihr könnt jetzt im Prinzip
die Torte füllen womit ihr möchtet und
noch einstreichen womit ihr möchtet
sollte einfach eine Unterlage sein die
schön fest wird damit ich später diesen
dripffekt eben auch machen kann ohne
dass die Creme schmilzt das heißt eine
Sahnecreme z.B geht nicht aber eine
frischkäsebuttercreme wird auch gehen
ich nehme jetzt die französische
Buttercreme und werde jetzt damit die
Torte wirklich schön glatt streichen das
heißt erst an der Oberfläche und dann
eben auch noch am
[Musik]
[Applaus]
Rand glatt streichen könnt ihr die Torte
am besten wenn ihr jetzt oben anfangt
das heißt ich nehme jetzt eine etwas
größere Palette und streich jetzt
erstmal die Oberseite der Torte glatt
und den Rand der Torte könnt ihr am
besten mit einer teigarte glatt
streichen die schön einen rechten Winkel
und den kann ich dann hier ansetzen und
die Torte währenddessen schön
[Musik]
drehen nach der ersten Tour sieht man
dann auch wo überall noch Buttercreme
fehlt da fühle ich jetzt noch mal auf
und ziehe sie dann noch mal schön
[Musik]
ab
jetzt stelle ich die Torte so für etwa
eine halbe Stunde in den Kühlschrank und
nehme dann die restliche Buttercreme um
einfach noch diese kleinen Löcher hier
zu füllen und dann ist sie
[Musik]
perfekt
die Torte ist jetzt schön glatt
gestrichen und ich kümmere mich um die
Dekoration also um den schönen Teil und
ich habe jetzt hier ein kleines Häschen
bereits vorbereitet aus
modellierschokolade ich nehme jetzt
dafür modellierschokolade weil ich super
einfach damit arbeiten kann die ist auch
für Anfänger geeignet und sie härtet
schnell aus das heißt ich kann heute die
Torte eben auch fertig stellen und ich
habe jetzt hier etwa 80 g weißer
modellierchokolade und habe sie auch
schon weich
geknetet jetzt habe ich sie zu so einer
Rolle geformt denn es kommt jetzt
einfach auf die Portionierung drauf an
das heißt ich mache jetzt hier zwei
kleine Striche und Drittel das
ganze zwei Drittel das ist der Körper
und dieses eine Drittel was ich jetzt
hier noch übrig habe drittle ich jetzt
wieder und hier nehme ich jetzt zwei
Drittel für den
Kopf und den Rest nehme ich jetzt für
das kleine Schwänzchen hier hinten und
für die Ohren jetzt FME ich aus dem
großen Teil erstmal eine Kugel und dann
einen tropfenförmigen
Körper der Kopf wird jetzt auch
tropfenförmig
geformt damit der Kopf jetzt auch einen
schönen Halt hat nehme ich einfach einen
Zahnstocher und piie den jetzt hier
rein jetzt müsst ihr nur drauf achten
dass der Kopf jetzt nicht mehr der
Spitze nach unten zeigt das Häschen soll
er mit der Nase nach oben sein bisschen
hochchauen so wie hier auch und das
heißt ich setze es einmal hier an und
steck es dann einfach hier drauf und
sollte etwas nicht gut halten nehmt ihr
einfach ein bisschen essbaren Kleber zum
[Musik]
befestigen
die Ohren werden jetzt ein bisschen
länglich geformt die Enden sind leicht
spitz dann drücke ich sie
flach und hier an der unteren Stelle ein
bisschen
gerade und nehme jetzt zum reinstecken
keine Zahnstocher sondern so eine kleine
Nudel das ist jetzt so eine suppennudel
ihr könnt auch Spaghettis nehmen und die
einfach ein bisschen kürzen die wird
jetzt hier
reingesteckt und dann könnt ihr die
modellierschokolade noch mal ein
bisschen drum rum drücken damit es auch
gut hebt und jetzt einfach mit einem
Modellierwerkzeug oder mit einem
stumpfen Messer z.B so eine kleine Linie
reinzeichnen und dann kann das erste Ohr
schon mal hier oben befestigt
[Musik]
werden für die Füße nehme ich jetzt eine
Kugel die hat etwa 2 cm im Durchmesser
die die halbiere ich jetzt so kann ich
immer sicherstellen dass beide Teile
gleich groß sind die formme ich jetzt
noch einmal zu einer
Kugel und dann leicht länglich also
wieder
tropfenförmig jetzt kann ich auch hier
mit einem Modellierwerkzeug oder einem
stumpfen Messer zwei Streifen
einzeichnen und das sind dann einfach
die
Pfoten den unteren Teil drücke ich jetzt
hier ein bisschen Dach und setzt dann
das Häschen drauf und klebt die Füße
einfach mit ein bisschen Druck oder
Essbarem Kleber
[Musik]
fest jetzt ist das süße Gesicht dran
dafür nehmem ich auch ein
Modellierwerkzeug und ich mache jetzt
hier zuerst einmal die Nase das heißt
hier habe ich die Mitte und Form ein
kleines
v
[Musik]
dann erkennt man auch schon das
hasengesicht dann kommt ein kleiner
Strich nach unten und dann nur noch nach
rechts und links der
[Musik]
Mund und mit einem kleinen balltool das
seht ihr jetzt hier ein kleiner Ball am
Werkzeug kann ich jetzt die Vertiefungen
für die Augen so ein bisschen
Eindrücken
damit die Häschen noch ein bisschen
Struktur bekommen nehme ich jetzt ein
feines Messer einen Cutter und werde
jetzt einfach so ein paar Striche
einritzen die sollen so ein bisschen das
Fell
darstellen und wenn ihr möchtet könnt
ihr auch gerne noch das Schwänzchen so
ein bisschen strukturieren und dafür
nehme ich jetzt eine gezackte
Tülle mit brauner und schwarzer
Pulverfarbe werde ich jetzt hier noch
ein paar Schattierungen reinmachen und
das Häschen einfach braun bepinseln und
dann nehme ich noch schwarze
modellerschokolade und werde die Augen
damit
[Musik]
machen
jetzt werden die Häschen angezogen dafür
nehme ich jetzt modellier Schokolade und
hier nehme ich ein bisschen bckersteckke
da Rolle ich es immer gern drauf aus und
jetzt mache ich erstmal das
Männchen schneide ich hier ein kleines
Rechteck
zu das lege ich jetzt einmal um den
Hasen um zu gucken ob es von der Größe
her passt aber es ist noch ein bisschen
zu
groß bäckersteig ist ganz toll weil man
sie ganz einfach mit dem Pinsel wieder
wegwischen
[Musik]
kann jetzt passt von der Größe her und
jetzt nehme ich ein präerad und werde
einfach die Nähte von der Nähmaschine so
ein bisschen
markieren
kommt hier einfach ein bisschen Kleber
dran und das Häschen wird dann
[Musik]
angezogen aus dem Restchen blau formme
ich jetzt noch zwei Arme und die klebe
ich hier dran und vorne muss dann noch
eine kleine weiße Hand dran die dann
eben auch braun eingefärbt wird
[Musik]
und du kleines Häschen bekommst eine
schirze
[Musik]
die Häschen wärden ja keine richtigen
Osterhasen wenn sie keine Farbe zum
Bemalen der Eier hätten also brauchen
sie auch Gefäße dafür und weil es eben
Hasen sind und keine Menschen haben sie
Hal keine Farbeimer also kriegen sie
jetzt hier aus Stein gemeiselt kleine
Farbtöpfe und die mache ich jetzt hier
aus modellierschokolade habe ein kleines
Stück geformt und nehme z.B ein balltool
oder ihr könnt auch den Daumen nehmen
und da so eine kleine Mulde reinformen
und damit so ein bisschen realistisch
aussieht werde ich die gleich mit etwas
schwarzer und weißer Pulverfarbe
bemalen
jetzt bekommt das Häschen noch eine
Schleife und dafür habe ich hier ein
bisschen modellierschokolade in dieses
kleine Silikonförmchen gedrückt ein
bisschen aushärten lassen und die
Schleife klebe ich jetzt hier oben ans
Ohr jetzt habe ich alles vorbereitet und
jetzt kommt der drip Effekt und den
werde ich jetzt mit Schokolade machen
und zwar nehme ich jetzt dafür weiße
Schokolade und Sahne und werd daraus
praktisch eine Ganache herstellen die
Sahne lass ich jetzt hier in einem Topf
kurz
aufkochen und sobald die Sahne kocht
stelle ich den Herd wieder aus und rüre
jetzt die Schokolade ein bis sie
komplett geschmolzen
ist die ganach ist jetzt bereit und
jetzt werde ich sie aufteilen denn ich
möchte sie ja noch einfärben ich mache
jetzt vier Schächen ihr könnt auch gerne
mehr oder weniger machen und eingefärbt
wird sie mit lebensmittelfarbpaste die
verändert nämlich die Konsistenz nicht
und verbindet sich auch ganz gut mit der
Schokolade und mit der
[Musik]
Sahne jetzt fange ich mit dem drip
Effekt an das heißt die verschiedenen
Farben werden jetzt hier am Rand
runterlaufen und zwar soll es am Ende so
aussehen als würden die zwei Häschen
oben auf der Torte sitzen die haben ihre
Farbeimer und die Eimer sind umge fallen
und die Farbe landet eben auf der Torte
statt auf den
[Musik]
Ostereiern
ich stell die Torte jetzt ganz kurz in
den Kühlschrank denn ich möchte dass
diese drips jetzt so fest werden wie sie
sind und dann geht's gleich weiter jetzt
habe ich hier ein paar süße Eier einmal
in schoko einmal überzogen mit Zucker
und werde die jetzt hier drauf setzen
gemeinsam mit den Farbtöpfen die ich
gleich noch befüllen
[Musik]
werde
unsere Torten sind jetzt fertig hier
habe ich meine große Torte und Samiras
wunderschöne Torte richtig schön mit dem
Hasen und vor allem finde ich hier vorne
die Tasche süß wo der Hase ein halbes
eiif versteckt er hast dir echt gut
überlegt super schön B so talentiert
Maus ich hab die Torte zerstört also
Morat es fällt mir schwer die Torte
anzuschneiden aber natürlich auch weil
sie eben sehr hoch ist so ist es aber
ich werde es jetzt trotzdem tun ich setz
aber vorher das das kleine Häschen
glaube ich ist natürlich ganz klar wenn
du eine Torte hochbst dann wirkt auch
sehr hoch ja ich schneide jetzt mal hier
hinten das war natürlich
logisch mor
logisch mus mal gerade runterchneiden
sonst sieht jeder wie nennst du deine
Torte
Samira wie nennst du deine tte
eigentlich hat i Namen ne
hanb
nein hasasi
[Musik]
hasiasi bereit ich drehe sie mal zu euch
bereit
[Musik]
dein Ernst jetzt was ist das riesenstück
für mich ehrlich jetzt ja also liebe
Zuschauer wer noch nicht gesehen hat ich
bin Murat ich wiege 2 Ton und fah
morgens mit LKW zur Arbeit auf der
Ladefläche nein ich habe natürlich das
große Stück rausgeschnitten für unser
Foto gleich also das war jetzt schon mal
fürs Foto vorbereitend jetzt werde ich
dir hiervon ein Stück abschneiden zum
Probieren okay okay also brauche ich
jetzt einfach noch ein Teller von dir
und dann schneide ich dir ein dünnes
Stück ab okay ein ganz dünnes Stück wie
du oh danke Schatz wie meine Mutter hat
d gerade richtig gedisst hast du mich
gerade gehatet ja soll nicht sein ja
Achtung Teller her also das ist jetzt
natürlich trotzdem als ich habe jetzt
ein schmales Stück
aber ist immer noch groß das ist immer
noch groß denn es ist ja doppelt so hoch
als normale Torten deswegen gebe ich dir
nur ein kleines Stück okay so und den
Rest nehme ich jetzt wieder cool eine
fruchteinlage ich ne an ist eine
himbeerfuchteinlage eine Achtung Finger
eine Waldfrucht fruchteinlage darf ich
bitte wieder mein Zimmer ja auf wieeders
sehen ich muss nm die Sam Mira geh jetzt
wieder weiter
malen richtig cool das tolle ist dass
die Waldfrucht säuerlich ist ja ich hab
die Einlage ist säuerlich und der Kuchen
ist eigentlich süß und das ist dann
perfekt oder ja was hast D noch drin
Pistazien oder
pistazienteig pistazienteig
ähm waldfruchteinlage himbeerbuttercreme
und vanillebuttercreme und bitte macht
es nach ja ganz ganz ganz lecker ganz
ehrlich das freut mich ich finde es
immer genial wenn man motivtotten
hinbekommt die auch wirklich schmecken
und das ist das ist das Wichtigste vor
allem ist der Murat echt ein sehr sehr
sehr großer Kritiker und wenn der sagt
ich schmeckt dann schmeckt es auch
wirklich mm wirklich vor allem mag ich
es halt ganz gerne weil ich die
waldfruchteinlage oder allgemein
fruchteinlagen nicht süße das heißt es
ist nur die Süße der Fruch ich woll es
gerade sagen es ist nicht süß nee es ist
einfach nur püriert eingekocht und mit
aga-aga vermischt einfach nur damit es
eben schön dick wird und haltbar bleibt
und ebeno wunderschön auch in der Torte
aussieht und falls ihr jetzt auch zu
Ostern diese Torte zubereiten wollt geht
auf sellis-blog.de da steht noch mal
ganz genau das Rezept ihr könnt die
Torte gerne genauso hoch machen oder
auch nur halb so hoch ihr könnt den
Durchmesser vergrößern macht die Torte
so wie ihr gerne möchtet und ich würde
natürlich gerne ein Foto davon sehen auf
Facebook oder auf Instagram viel Spaß
beim Nachmachen und bis zum nächsten Mal
tschüss tschüss zum Glück habe ich dir
nch ein halbes Tortenstück gegessen
sonst hättest Du jetzt die Viertel Torte
aufgegessen oder ja Torte le ja schon
weg aber dasass ganz ehrlich ganz großes
kN ich fahre jetzt nach Hause mit meinem
LKW auf der nadeflech tschüss viel Spaß
[Musik]
tut